انتظار ورئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد الشاعر
السوداني لاكتمالي اعضاء حكومته وصل الى
نهايته اخيرا بالحصول على ثقه البرلمان
منذ 27 من اكتوبر الماضينا لواحد 21 وزيرا
من اعضاء الحكومه الثقه ويوم امس منح
البرلمان ثقته لاخر وزيرين وزير البيئه
والاعمار وبالاغلبيه المطلقه التصويت على
الوزارتين تاجل بسبب خلاف بين الحزبين
الكرديين الرئيسيين الديمقراطي والاتحاد
الوطني الى ان اتى الاعلان الجديد ليتقسم
الحزبان الوزارتين
وتحضها ثاني الحقيبتان باهميه بالغه في
سياق تصدي الحكومه العراقيه لما تواجهه
البلاد من تحديات وازماته منها الجفاف
والتصحر وانتشار العشوائيات وتهلك البنا
التحتيه في المدن
وكان السوداني شددا خلال عرض برنامج عمل
الحكومه على تمسكه بالسعي لتحسين وتطوير
الخدمات التي تمص حياه المواطنين في وقت
تواجهه ملفات شائكه منها الفساد واصلاح
الاقتصاد والمؤسسات الرسميه
[موسيقى]
من جديد تعود الخلافات بين مكونات الاطار
التنسيقيه بسبب حصص كل مكون في الاطار
لشغل الوظائف المهمه صحيفه المدى العراقيه
اشارت الى ان رئيس الوزراء محمد الشيعه
السوداني يتعرض للضغط من قبل ائتلاف دوله
القانون لاحداثي مزيدا من التغيير في
المناصب نتحدث هنا عن اكثر من 10,000 منصب
تعرف بالدرجات الخاصه
بالوكاله منذ ما يزيد عن 10 سنوات
سوداني طرح تصوره سابقا بشان شغل المناصب
وهو التريث ودراسه كل موقع وظروفه على
احداث المدى نقلت عن مصادر مقربه من
الاطار قولها ان الاطراف التي تضغط على
رئيس الحكومه تحاول اجراء ما يشبه التطهير
السياسي في تلك المناصب المصادر اضافت ان
الحديث يدور حول تغيير 900 منصب دفعه
واحده يغلب عليها مناصب في قطاعات الامنيه
وتحديدا في وزارتي الدفاع والداخليه في
هذا الاطار اشارت المصادر الى ان زعيم
دوله القانون نور المالكي يرفض تولي اعضاء
ميليشيا عصائب اهل الحق مناصب المخابرات
او الامن القومي ايضا بحسب لائحه
التغييرات المسربه يتبين وجود ما يشبه
الاستهداف لفريق رئيس الوزراء السابق
مصطفى الكاظمي الذي تم ابعاد المستشارين
الذين عملوا معه قبل التوجه للاسماء
الاخرى في اللائحه
[موسيقى]